so this is the part three the passions
of the soul and we've covered a lot of
ground we've talked about the
relationship between the line in the
body which is mysterious I'm complicated
that they card a social theory about
that and I way he's owned enough
passions passions or ways in which the
brain and what's going on in the brain
and how its reacting downside events and
how it's taking positions is affecting
the minds what we actually perceive what
we sense in our consciousness then we
talked about these six basic passions
and we spent a lot of time going over
those they are are how they work you
know how love is different settings
designer what wonder is all that in this
third part Descartes is I'm doing two
things he's talking about more specific
passions that are their modalities or
competence from these basic passions and
then he's wrapping everything up and
what I want to do that at the start is
begin with the ramp up that gives you an
idea of why he's talking about these
these particular things so we touched on
this at the end of last class session
the passions there's a point to them
they help us to live the kind of lives
for the kind of beings that we are both
mind and body and we we have to watch
out for our bodies alright so you know
you can't just eat anything and survive
things that taste bad for you are
generally bad for you although we live
in a weird kind of Wonderland now where
all sorts of things that actually are
bad for you tastes wonderful because
science of chemistry to make that so but
in general things in the wild that
tastes awful
don't eat up they're bad for you things
that taste pretty good usually pretty
good for you
those are modes of pleasure and pain
those are modes of joy and sadness take
heart let's say you have things like
love or hatred
those are centering on
we have the things are beneficial for us
or harmful for us so we get mixed up
about these things a lot but in general
we we hate the things that we at least
proceed whether they are truly or not
bad for us and when something hurts us
then we we begin to heat it we desire to
not have a bias with an aversion towards
it and when we have experiences and we
like things things feel good for us they
turn out well we begin to love those
things
then there's Wonder and Wonder helps us
to you know focus our attention on
things
all of these can have problems with them
all of them can become excessive but
they're all in some way oriented towards
good things for his body soul composit
which is a human person so Descartes
doesn't want us not to have emotions he
doesn't want us to simply rein him in
and get rid of them altogether at the
very end of this part he's talking about
a general remedy for the passions and
remedy makes us sound like he's trying
to get rid of it right when you have a
remedy for our sickness you're trying to
get rid of it
so think about love you know would your
life be better off just think about
romantic love people often make this
kind of choice would your life be better
off if you kept yourself from having any
sort of romantic feelings for anybody
because then you'll never get hurt right
don't people try to do that sometimes
usually after a terrible breakup yeah
if you were to do that you deprive
yourself of a great good though a good
for the body and for the soul so he
doesn't mean remedy in that sense
think of it more like imagine yourself
as a diabetic you're a diabetic what do
you have to do do you have to just like
stop eating sweet things altogether I
suppose if you're really really badly
off maybe what do you have to do did any
of your relatives for diabetic what do
you have to do you have just watch sighs
yeah I didn't have to take some medicine
I said insulin now that now you can take
it all different ways but what you're
talking about is even more important
monitoring diet exercise having some
sort of regimen in place that's what
he's talking about as a remedy for the
passion so he says now that we've met up
with all the actions we have much less
reason for any anxiety about that that
we had before it we're going to come
back to that anxiety we see that they're
all intrinsically good so hatred is good
sadness is good intrinsically in itself
doesn't feel good to be sad right
doesn't feel good hate but it's actually
good for you in some some respect
because you know you shouldn't hate some
things that are actually bad for you
shouldn't like me poking you in the eye
you should hate that you should hate me
if I keep doing them so he says all we
have to avoid is their misuse or their
excess and that's exactly what some sort
of regimen for somebody who has an
illness is trying to do avoid excess
over here avoid too much being
abstentions or ascetic as well you know
it's not good for diabetics to starve
themselves the remedies I presented
could be sufficient if everybody took
the trouble to apply them so we're going
to look at those those remedies but the
thing I want to focus on first we have
these passions and the passions can
cause us pain and suffering
some of them are by themselves painful
to feel hatred it's no fun when you're
angry that doesn't feel good either
right when you're sad when your body
doesn't feel feel good that doesn't you
know you don't enjoy that at home some
people get into weird you know sort of
feedback loops what they do but but
usually that's because that makes them
on some level happiness now notice he
talks about not pain and suffering here
but anxiety or in other word for that is
here lesson our emotions are things that
can cause us to feel other emotions so
fear why why should we feel fear with
respect to our emotions because we know
from experience they can lead us astray
right have you ever been creative of
your own anger this happens too it's a
little children infants actually they
something happens they get really upset
suddenly there's this kind of soft
reflective moment and they get scared of
their own your own anger and that can
happen to you as an adult you do stupid
things when you're angry
when you say terrible things to people
or you know break things or you know
destroy relationships by defriending
them on Facebook or things like that if
you're gonna do that probably a good
idea well that can make you afraid or
have you ever been really happy and yet
you have this nagging feeling that
blends the other shoe gonna fall this is
too good or you know you could say
either then you actually feel anxious
about how sad you feel about how other
people are going to take
am i depressed or you know will I be
able to function
love and hate work that way too so we
don't actually have to have fear which
by itself is a passion about our
passions if we can aquila understand
them and then we put in place a kind of
regime a kind of diets diet by the way
originally didn't just mean food they
meant a way of life that's the original
sense of the term Greek Greek physicians
wouldn't decide hey lose some weight you
know quit eating so much they would say
exercise they would say do this as well
think about these things so the Curtis
is giving you something like that
interestingly enough do you guys know
what the de cartes day job was when he
wasn't writing philosophy and doing
experiments anybody know I can get a
degree in medicine he was a doctor he'd
go into medical school he also had a law
degree - it was kind of a Patrick so he
says how can we do this up he says hard
work in advance is needed if we want to
deal with their passions why do you have
to do work in advance if you want to do
it I feel ya
that's an important part actually self
knowledge about what anger looks like
for you what sadness looks like for you
what the M looks like for you how do you
tell the difference between being joyful
and being Bannock
you know so knowing your limitations
that's very important
why else why else should you prepare in
advance what is it like when you feel
something strongly need you to think
about things especially that feeling I
think about getting really angry what
happens to you when you get really angry
psychologically yeah there's there's a
great anger management book and the very
first line of it says as soon as you
become angry you become stupid doesn't
matter how intelligent you are you
become stupid and become so stupid you
don't realize how stupid you are
and it doesn't mean that you're like you
know stupid in the sense like you know
your brain is no longer working what it
means is that you cease being rational
and you see some tending to things that
you shouldn't you should pay attention
to and anger by itself or or you know
sadness or joy they don't have this sort
of self governing mechanism they can't
tell you hey there's too much of me here
they usually say let's have some more so
once you actually start feeling things
that's not the time that to begin you
know doing your exercises that's really
saying with respect to the actual
physical exercise
we'll start you know fetching 500 that's
an awful lot of weight but you know just
imagine that I've seen people do it it's
quite amazing no much no not 500 like
like 300 or 400 you're gonna start doing
it like that you're gonna walk into the
gym and just head over there start
putting all those weights on and just
push it up
that won't happen without a lot of
exercise before matter of fact you know
one of the things that happens when you
go to the gym for the first time is
usually you put on too much weight don't
you I mean you're terribly sore the next
day it's the same thing with our
emotions
he says the objects of the passions
around movements in the blood remember
he talks about one that felt that follow
so fast from your impressions and the
brand the disposition the organs with no
input from the soul that no amount of
human wisdom can counteract those
movements less preparations have been
made in advance now we don't think that
anger is above blood anymore we think
it's about you know electrical impulses
and adrenaline and other hormones and
things like that going through your body
sadness is like that to desire for
further attacks from there for security
all these sorts of things a version in
our earth startled reaction these things
are all very powerful and they happen so
quickly and they happen so automatically
within the body in the brain but often
times we can't think about them we can't
even tell like when we get angry we
can't tell that we're already so angry
so we need to prepare in advance to be
able to handle these things he says one
thing we can do is we can be on our
guard and bear in mind that everything
presented to the imagination tends to
mislead the soul and make the reasons
for pursuing the object of its passion
appear much stronger than they are and
the reasons for not pursuing it much
weaker so again with respect to anger if
you actually are armed ahead of time
with this or the thing and you get angry
you can tell yourself you know generally
when I get
become kind of stupid and inattentive to
everything other than what made me angry
and I tend to think that the things that
I'm angry about really matter more than
they do and I tend to ignore the other
things like relationships or not being a
jerk or you know rules of fair play that
I want to be paying attention to you can
tell yourself that sort of thing
yeah the may or may not work I had some
times that anger still carries you away
or when you get sad you know think about
you know I'm willing to bet that most of
you have experienced a bad breakup
romantically at one point or another at
this stage in your life
and if not you probably you're probably
going to sooner or later unless you you
know find another person for you and or
you just you know don't get involved
with anybody ever
what's it like when you have a bad
breakup your your feelings what does
that make you want to get if you can't I
mean your experience of the think about
your friends or movies or things like
that yeah
yeah character picture is get scissors
snip here's your picture throw theirs in
the trash talk bad about them you want
your friends to talk bad about them too
right
so you bring everybody else eh what else
that's a good that's a good start
that's a perfect anger what else
I know Brooks likes to eat ice cream
well that's like a movie stereotype
right there's a breakup and somebody's
by the refrigerators of you think that
like right now about the gallon carton
yeah okay so people have desired for
food but it's actually a scientific
basis they found it for this you know
fatty foods sweet foods salty foods who
are you gonna say yeah turn the tables
on em er yeah okay drowning your sorrows
right you know there's a desire for
drink oftentimes people will like go out
to the bar not just because they want to
get drunk but because they actually want
to be around other people who aren't
that person who they're they're upset
with maybe they want them to commiserate
there's a feeling of sadness too right
deep sadness yeah work out a lot yeah I
think you're right there are some people
use that as the stress response to
everything which all things you know
considered that's probably better than
eating ice cream or getting really angry
you know at least it doesn't doesn't
screw up your body and come out you know
feeling a bit healthier now what's going
on there
you know the the feelings about the
break-up they're not they're not
governing themselves if you're steering
you toward certain things having desires
loves hates anger few other different
emotions and they give you the
impression that this is something I'd
really like to do like some people will
reorganize their
music collection I really need to do
this one thing
or they taint their apartment you know
they have to repaint everything and they
get really obsessive about getting the
trim just right the colors just right
what's going on there this is what they
card is talking about reasons for
pursuing the object of the passion
appear much stronger than me this is
this is part of what the passions do and
the reasons for not pursuing it become
much weaker so it screws up our sense of
perspective right if you become aware of
that again you might be a little bit
worried when you start realizing just
how skewed your perspective is so what
the Qura actually advise us to is
another thing we can try to do when
we're feeling strong passions is delay
making any decisions about the things
that passions are steering us towards so
you get into a really bad breakup is
that the time to jump into like a
radically new project or get rid of all
your clothes and buy new clothes and
change who you are probably not that's
probably a bad idea that's the feeling
talking not reason talking and you know
later on you come to regret it or think
about rebound relationships
what would rebound relationships people
have a bad breakup they find somebody
else the main thing that that somebody
else has is they're not this person over
here and how often do those rebound
relationships work out not too often
that's not a good basis for following
your you know your desire for
companionship for Saks court or all the
other things that come with
relationships so Descartes says delay
making any decision about the things of
passions dearest courts and think about
other things
this sounds like stupid advice right
when you've gone through a bad breakup
somebody says what let's do some ribs
let's let's play you know video games
where let's go to the zoo or let's talk
about some other topic and then you
talk about how awful that person is but
that's actually good advice for anger -
anger management they tell you if you
can keep your mind off of it for about
10 minutes and think about something
else you'll actually calm down you'll
feel less angry not just think less
angry you'll feel less angry in your
body doesn't work by the way if you
spend your time thinking about that
person and how they made you angry or
the things that they've done in the past
that's not going to work but if you can
think about unicorns or ping pong balls
or anything just trivial say anything
stupid for ten minutes you'll actually
start to feel better
they curtains onto something so the
other thing I want to point towards with
this so there's some you know we could
diet with respect to the passions he
says all the good of his life depends
solely on the passions he and so does
all the evil that's a really interesting
thing to say all the good of this what
does he mean by this life well we are
bodies United with souls all the good
that we can experience ultimately has to
do with how we feel not just how we
think so for the guy who said you know I
think therefore I am
he's an awful lot about feeling this
isn't he says this is the pleasures that
the soul shares of the body have been
entirely on the passions so that person
whom the passions can move most deeply
are capable of enjoying the sweetest
pleasures of this life so maker tis not
saying you just want to you know mute
the passions down as a matter of fact if
you want to have the happiest life you
have to feel very deeply but you want
them to be directed in the right ways
not not going off leading humans ulcers
crazy predict of us he says there's a
bad side of this it's true they may also
experience the most
yes when they don't know how to put
these passions to good use when fortune
works against now fortune that's luck
you don't have any control over that but
you do have control over your passions
not directly but indirectly by choosing
to think about them the right way to do
the right things with them to put in
place kind of a a an exercise routine so
all that said let's look now at some of
these specific reactions that they part
focuses on sorry so we talked last time
about Wonder and the Curt says that this
leads us to feeling some some other
things as well and with Wonder we can
feel the steam or we can feel contempt
and the steam is when we view something
as having high value contempt is when we
view it as having low or no matter yeah
and this is relative right so it's not
as if things just intrinsically possess
the value they have we give things value
by the huff look that we have and how do
we measure value there's there some ways
we you do it quite easily think about
this the holiday season is coming up
you're going to be buying gifts are you
gonna get these gifts what means of
value are you going to exchange for the
gifts money right so money is one way we
we measured that
let's take I don't know if anything
about backpacks I will say we can take
backpacks for instance but I have no
idea looking down this row of backpacks
I'm so nicely arranged actually I mean
look at it it's like a perfect five in a
row which of those is the most expensive
I have no idea which is the best
backpack I don't know which is you know
which is the one that that somebody most
want to to hold an ISD even when it
comes to tie so I'm not a good judge of
that and we have that up to like my wife
to the side it works I could tell you
about books which books are schlock and
crap and which books you guys read yeah
and yeah valuation is very often opinion
it's a value judgment we say and I make
value things differently than you do
these are passions that are felt by
people and the passions that I feel
those passions I have they may not be
the ones that you have there are certain
public ways in which we try to get on
the same page like you know if I said to
you let's say you really like my tie is
like I'll give this to you for a million
dollars you say well you're nuts
because I'm not gonna give you $100 you
know I'll give you maybe ten dollars for
going back and forth you know what that
handling processes is a convergence of
opinion about value and neither one of
us is entirely happy right because you
actually think it should be over here I
think it should be over here but we do
have some sort of standards know your
entire curriculum that you're studying
here at Marist is the product of a whole
bunch of professors getting together
years ago and hashing out over arguments
with each other what you ought to be
studying professors that may not even be
here anymore decided is this stuff for
you and you're kind of caught within
that me
but that that has to do with valuation
so we can we can value things as highly
we can steam them where we can contend
them we can also feel this about
ourselves can't we can think of
ourselves as a person with high value or
we can look down upon ourselves so he
says these can relate to all sorts of
objects they're most conspicuous when we
related it to ourselves so what is that
when we relate them to ourselves what
can cause us to esteem ourselves that's
a good question
- some people think too highly of
themselves when they shouldn't
near experience some people think too
lowly of themselves as well you have a
friend who's always tearing themselves
down you know they're a great person
they can't see that about themselves so
he talks about generosity and he says
true generosity brings it about that a
person's self-esteem is as great as it
legitimately can be consists only in
knowing that nothing truly belongs to
the person except his free control over
his will or Carlow and that the good or
bad use of this freedom is the only
valid reason for him to be praised or
blamed now think about all the different
things we praise or blame people blaming
means criticizing all the things we vote
people up on or vote people down
so think about looks we have some
control over your looks right I mean you
can decide to take showers or not wash
it here don't wash your hair wear
clothing that that actually fits you it
looks good you know with your skin tone
or not what else can you do you can work
out or not work out eat healthy or eat
stuff that will give you you know all
sorts of facial problems but a lot of
that's audio control design I'll tell
you know I'll tell you are do you have
control over that that you know shrink
down your you're too tall like me you
know it'd be life would be more
comfortable for you if you were you know
about 5 foot 10 I mean you you know what
it's like to try to pack yourself into
car seats and on planes and things like
that well you don't have any control
over it do those of you who are shorter
get taller
just make it happen thank you well I'll
put on some platform shoes but that's
not really making your taller you know a
lot of beauty is is a matter of facial
symmetry you got the face you're born
with and it's gonna change over time and
you're kind of stuck with it you're by
the way is you can older your ears are
gonna keep growing you know this is
gonna keep growing so if you're
good-looking now you may not be as
good-looking ten years from now or 20
years from now if you're not
good-looking now if your nose is too
small maybe it's gonna get bigger you
don't have control over that sort of
thing
it's not the sort of thing we should
really esteem or contemporary songs for
what about money having a lot of money
you know that's a big one in our society
and we shouldn't feel bad about it being
a big one in our society because it's a
big one in every human society every
human society has people who aren't
valued solely on the basis of having
well usually on the basis of having
inherited it or you know gotten it from
from somebody in some some underhanded
way that's not really something to to
esteem yourself or if you're rich that's
good that's fine it's not to say you
should try to be four because being poor
by itself is not something good you know
it's going to be irrelevant having lots
of friends that gets a little bit closer
if you have a lot of friends because you
just kiss everybody's rear-end that's
probably not a good thing if you have a
lot of friends because they want to get
something from you probably not a good
thing either right if you have a lot of
friends because you have a genuinely
good character and people see that and
they want to hang out with you that's
probably a reflection of what he's
talking about here with your will
you know what you've chosen for yourself
the character so this condition of
generosity which is you know sort of
decart's key virtue he says comes from
knowing that nothing truly belongs to
the person except for free control over
their choices and good or bad use of
this this freedom is the only valid
reason for a person to be praised or
blamed that's the only thing that makes
a person a good person a bad person
along with that he says this person's
feeling within themselves a firm
inconstant resolution to use their
freedom left to use that that human
freedom that they have never to lack the
will to undertake and carry out whatever
they judge to be best now notice what he
says about this if we actually have this
kind of attitude how are we going to
behave towards other people there's two
ways you could go at this you could be
like well let's assume that I actually
have this attitude which I don't because
you know it's kind of a high achievers I
could say well you know I actually value
myself for the right reasons and I have
this firm resolution do the right thing
with my well looking at other people
they're not like that so they're not
good matter of fact I should look down
at them does that sound right to you if
I have this attitude that the only thing
that's really good or bad about me is
the choices that I make the kind of
person I choose to be would it make
sense for me to look down on everybody
guys at first it is right what really
makes sense if you think it through
what's your feeling
yeah yeah yeah no he he doesn't mean
respect other people like in the sense
of thinking that they're better than
they are you respect their potential
they could be like that the card has
this interesting attitude towards human
beings somebody like Aristotle would say
if you're ambitious you're screwed you
have you've damaged yourself so much
that you're probably not going to be
able to get yourself out of that cuz
you're so screwed up then you think the
way that you're behaving is the right
way and you know what are you gonna do
with somebody like that you know
Descartes would say no everybody
everybody can change it's gonna be tough
harder for some people to change than
others like at your age it's a lot
easier for you to change that is for
somebody you know my age the dumb
mistakes that I've made even ones when I
was strange
about my character are they have a more
weight to them you have a bit more
control over them but even even I can
change if I want to according to her so
if I think about this you know you guys
are all have characters that are fairly
well established but you have some
control over at this point what if I'm
looking at little kids you know like
like five year olds three year olds
they're characters they show in certain
respects some kids are bad kids some
kids are good kids
some are you know nice some are mean but
then a lot could change
couldn't it there's so much that could
change I could just look down on to say
anything established but I recognize
their potential and in recognizing their
potential as human beings that I can
value that I can have what you call
respecting now he also talks about
humility and he says the most generous
people are also usually the humblest
humble in what sense
we have humility as a virtue win by
reflecting on the affirmative your
nature and the wrongs we may have
could yet do we don't rate ourselves
higher than anyone else and we think
that since others have free will just as
we do they may they may use it just as
well as we desires so even if you're
squared away if you actually have this
this condition of generosity which
Aristotle had a different word for magna
magnanimity you want it down on others
you also won't push yourself up too high
because you realize not only can others
be doing the right thing they have the
potential for that you have the
potential for screwing up if things
didn't go a little bit differently for
you maybe you'd be more screwed up than
you are now you know I remember just
wanting cases playing there was a period
where I was actually when I was 16 and
7.7 just 16 years old I was a ward of
the court because I was such a bad kid
that my mom actually filed what was
called an uncontrollability petition
saying I can't do anything with this kid
let the state take it and I was a bad
kid
and actually deserved that and like a
lot of bad kids I thought it wasn't a
bad you know so I got thrown in with all
these other bad kids and this this place
it was sort of like a holding tank you
know you weren't supposed to be there
long term if they thought they had to
figure out where it we're descending
that's juvenile detention or you know
some sort of rehab place or things like
that and I got stuck there for like 12
hour days so it wasn't really meant for
that sort of thing yeah I hadn't hit all
sorts of they had temper issues so I was
acting like a jerk I was pretty much a
jerk non-stop anyway and I had this guy
who who brought me into his office and
sat me down and you know he put up with
quite a bit of my might be a spy that
was like about four or five days in and
he said to me look I just want you to
listen to this I just
attention don't take this personally but
your it used a different word here I'm
just gonna say Jared you're really a
jerk yeah if you don't want people to
treat you like a jerk like a jerk and
for some reason it was the right thing
at the right time it like made an
impression on me and I actually thought
about it I thought yeah actually I
better fix this now if I haven't had him
coming along at that time who knows how
badly off I'd be I'm still not you know
where Descartes would want us to be and
if you think about these sorts of things
do you think about the fact that many of
us get parents who may not like you know
as much as they're pretty good parents
overall we didn't have to have that that
didn't have to be the case for us we had
a lot of opportunities people have put
up a lot of our nonsense that can't
humble you that can be very helpful in
introducing us this counter
[Applause]
is counter virtuous humility
so generosity means recognizing
everything depends on on you and your
choices and that other people are in
that condition as well and realizing
that you could have screwed up those
choices and you can still screw up those
dresses you can't just rest on your on
your laurels
now he opposes to this some other things
he says what about people who are vain
vanity says anyone who gets a good
opinion of himself for any reason other
than what we just talked about you know
your choices doesn't have true
generosity but a vanity that's always
very far from the virtue the less
justification they have for esteeming
themselves highly the greater the
distance from virtue the least justified
is a person who is vain for no reason at
all not because he thinks he has some
merit for which he should be appreciated
there are some people who think that
they don't have anything to anger them
but you should still like you don't
treat them with the utmost respect that
they're totally deserving of it they
feel what we call in Thailand right is
that part of the entitlement mentality
everybody deserves a gold star just for
walking in that sort of mentality that's
actually vanity that's not that's not
this this passion of generosity it's not
having any correct evaluation of
yourself this goes to that the question
about opinion right a person can have
too high of an opinion of themselves
that's not really based on anything and
unfortunately you know we live in a
society like every other society that
has ever existed and probably will exist
where well good looks connections
position where are the things that
people pride themselves on who they who
they're dating who they're married to
whether they have good taste and food
and wine what movies they're into what
music they're into go through all these
sorts of things
people will often rate themselves highly
over these sort of things the sports
fans great example sports allegiances
are irrational
I love the Packers I'm perfectly willing
to say that my attachment to them
totally irrational Packers fans are not
better than Vikings fans as people but I
look down on Vikings fans from a
Cartesian perspective that's wholly
stupid right
if I were they actually like get into a
fight with a Vikings fan at the game
they have these things now you know
hackers have the cheesehead things you
have people wear a cheese grater now you
know get into a fight with this guy that
would be insane I'm holding myself to
this super high value over something
totally arbitrary the other person is
holding I'm holding them to a low value
or something equally arbitrary that's
vanity people would do this over clothes
again vanity or cars another great
example right how does your car look
kind of car do you drive that doesn't
make you a good person a bad person only
your choices do so vanity is is very far
from virtue would there be another thing
that would be far from virtue that has
to do with these evaluations we're gonna
get the jealousy jealousy has to do with
something a little bit different in this
range so you can value yourself too high
what's the opposite of that too low and
humility sometimes when we're talking
about humility what I mean as a person
is a real correct estimate of who they
are and how easy it would be for them to
be somebody different if they made the
wrong choices weren't that they could
still make the wrong choices
that's not everybody's humility though
right you also know that people are
always going around what was me my life
sucks so much I'm nobody and no good
that's also sort of like vanity only
it's going in
other direction he says for someone to
be abject or and virtuously humblest
chiefly for these things to be true of
them they have a feeling of weakness or
indecision they're unable to like commit
to something they can't help doing
things that they know they'll be sorry
about later on is if they lacked full
use of their will and they believe they
can't survive on a tit or do without
many things whose acquisition depends on
others so he says this is directly
opposed to generosity it often happens
the most abject people are the most
arrogant to Ponty there's kind of a back
and forth if you're very humble like
that and things go good for you suddenly
you become vain vain people those two
those things you know the things that
they have that they were you know
wanting themselves I go away they
suddenly become this unvirtuous humble
person because they don't have a correct
estimate of what's really good and
what's really bad so think about
somebody who's prided themselves on
their looks for a very long time take
away their looks
suddenly they feel like they're empty
they have nothing to offer probably they
do have nothing at that point in time
because all they have done is basic you
know based on your books could they
change their life and you know become a
different person who actually does good
things sure a lot of times they don't
they just go around self-pity right and
they themselves miserable and everybody
else miserable so I'm gonna skip over
how he discusses Jeff how generosity is
acquired let's move on and look at
things like hope and and anxiety this is
a whole different modality of emotions
and these have to do mainly with desire
but they have to do with desire and our
estimates of whether we can attain what
it is that we want to or not and so we
have opposed here our hope and
anxiety another word for that is here we
have hope when we think there's a good
chance that we can actually get what we
desire now that's what it means to hope
right we have fear when we think that
it's uncertain or no chance or bad
chance a chance and one of these become
very extreme they can become what
Descartes calls confidence when you are
pretty certain that you're going to get
what it is that you want you're you're
confident and despair is when you're
pretty assured that you're just not
going to get it so you know think about
right now going into finals week some
classes I'm willing to bet that for each
of you there is some class that you
think you've got a lock you've got an A
in that class you know whatever maybe a
lot of the other classes you're
confident about that one and then
there's some where you feel some anxiety
or some fears there may actually be some
where you're actually despairing
although that's probably not you that's
more likely the students that are not
here and they're gonna show up on exam
day and haven't been here for a while
and just want to like see whether
there's any possibility of pulling the
the the proverbial chestnuts out of the
fire you guys are probably wavering
between these two quite a bit same thing
to go for job prospects something you
don't have to worry about quite yeah
thank thank goodness but you should
start thinking about you know when
you're gonna start doing your
internships stuff like that right now
you probably have some degree of anxiety
about the job market that you're
eventually going out into you'd be a
rational doctor you shouldn't feel the
spirit out
as a matter of fact I think all of you
should probably feel more Hope than fear
because you're smart you apply
yourselves you're probably going to do
okay probably you know let's not
guaranteed there's probably more reason
for you to hold that to fear some of the
other students who have taught in my
life
probably have way too much hope like I
you know I used to teach these students
who were coming in with 800 SATs and
they would tell me they were very lost
where after they graduated I'd say I
don't think so
you know they were confident about it
because I'm shaking I think what's gonna
happen that Mozilla I'll get you know
finish start applying realize how hard
the LSAT sighs and then they'll fill the
spare but these are all modalities yeah
and these are very important now getting
to jealousy what is what does the card
say that jealousy is jealousy is a kind
of anxiety having to do with our desire
to keep possession of so I'm good so we
could be jealous what do we usually
think about jealousy having to do it
what kind of good
peanutbutter cups that really
what do we what do we usually yeah like
other people attention and one other
thing that they they have to I will come
back to that in a moment stick with the
other people so we have attention right
you know I give somebody attention
somebody else would like that attention
what else though thank you a faction
very good so when I am if I didn't say
feeling jealousy with respect to my wife
let's say my wife begins having an
emotional affair as we call it you know
torrid internet discussions through
Gmail our google chat with with some
some other guy right now I become
jealous I'm becoming jealous about the
fact that she is giving the attention in
a faction that I feel ought to belong to
me to somebody else all right and does
it always have to be the case that the
person is actually doing that for
somebody to feel jealous no some people
can feel jealousy over nothing isn't
that true have any of you ever had a a
over jealous boyfriend or girlfriend
none of you do okay see some nodding
hands
what's that like look was Adam what do
you you could see the gears in their
head moving what sort of things are
happening yeah
that's the effect now what's what's the
actual thought process how does it sound
that good oh that's it that's that's
correct yeah there's some sort of like
gesture yeah you know thinking you go to
a restaurant you the waiter or waitress
approaches you thank them and you
maintain eye-contact cuz that's a nice
thing to do right
treat a person like a person you want to
sleep with that alright how did you get
from point A over here to point B over
here what kind of thought process was
required
well that's described what is it what
does it actually stop what are some sort
of specifics how do you get from thanks
it was a good dinner to here's that
here's the tip you left too big of a tip
you want to sleep with them that's a big
leaf isn't it yeah my previous
boyfriend/girlfriend did this and made
XYZ so I know you're gonna do the same
thing that's how people become the
houses yeah I don't trust you you know
okay yeah you might be doing this
reasoning quite often going from Mike to
our you might be doing this or this is a
possibility so I know that it's
happening so all that can be wrapped up
in this with this emotion of jealousy
and now it can also be about non
personal goods to material objects you
can be jealous again believes it's time
for an example I could be jealous about
this this time I think blessing I
irrationally believe that everybody else
wants my tie because all of you you know
say how much data do you need to find a
Christmas gift for and you know if you
stole my tie because it's a nice tie you
could check that one off your list
notice a rational thinking right deeply
rational thinking but I'm feeling what's
the passion here about my ability to
continue to keep a good that I want to
keep the card he asked us a really
interesting question about this can
jealousy be good
are there cases where jealousy could be
warranted or is it always a bad thing to
feel that's dangerous but I see where
you're going with that yeah it does it
does convey caring it could convey
caring pathologically in ways they're
scary but you're right yeah there's I
mean there's four examples we use my
wife at that if I notice my wife like
let's say I actually like keep track of
the finances and I don't know so there's
all these hotel bills let's make it more
time Motel bills and they like happen
every you know week when she's supposed
to be teaching a class at night and I
you know I call up the motel and I say
I'm really you know curious about this
sort of thing is my wife checking in
there yeah she's checking in with the
same guy each week in that case I
probably should be jealous right yeah
and maybe it does convey like yeah I
think you're right I think that maybe
we're moving into a different different
kind of emotion yeah
okay so they were talking about
something that in our culture we often
mistake for jealousy sticker trucks and
not just a cart with a lot of other
ancient medieval modern theorists of
emotion talk about two other emotions
one is is Envy Envy is different than
jealousy jealousy is where you want to
hold on to the good yeah
envy of another person's good is being
unhappy that they they haven't been
wanting it for yourself so if you're
like I could be envious of all of your
youth for example no because that's not
good I think it's a bad thing that you
guys have you know youth and vitality
and good health you do that's not that's
not the same thing as being jealous what
you're talking about though isn't
anything there's a different word for it
it's called emulation emulation is where
you feel a sense of pain in relation to
another person who has some sort of good
but they deserve that good and you wish
that you have that for yourself usually
it's in terms of like achievements right
soul and here would be a great example
again with respect is bless you thank
you let's say my relationship isn't that
good and I look at somebody else in
their marriage seems like it's perfect
and all that and I'm like geez why can't
I get it together
how's that I didn't even know we had fun
in here all right so hopefully we won't
ring again or what else you know like
people's achievements in sports you know
I I will never be in any sport that I
watch accomplished to the level of the
people who I
to watch I wish I could be that would be
a good thing for me but I recognize that
it's a good for them and I don't have
any bad feelings towards them because of
it if I felt enemy I'd have bad feelings
towards them if I actually have these
these skills and I didn't want other
people to acquire them not even jealous
of them or I can be jealous of my
reputation so so those are good good
distinctions to make the curt says you
could be jealous legitimately in a few
cases a captain defending a very
important fortress as a right to be
jealous of it so you're assigned this
task hold this position hold the line
you can feel a sense of jealousy you
don't want the enemy taking it from you
that's a weird to call that jealousy I
think but it does make sense the
virtuous woman is not blamed for being
jealous of her honor what are you
talking about there is there is this big
emphasis on preserving virginity until
marriage you know
euphemistic terms for that but that's
not something to be jealous that's not
something bad to be jealous about to
hold on to the capacities that you
actually have your skills holding on to
a position that you actually deserve
that's probably a good kind of jealousy
so that's that let's talk about another
thing it's like a indecision indecision
is a kind of anxiety since keeping the
sole balance between several actions
open to us indecision causes it not to
perform any of them have you ever been
in a state like that but you can't you
can't decide and somebody else decides
from the outside for you yeah he says
this is this is really bad and it goes
on too long as it keeps us from from
acting when we should sometimes it could
be good for us to be indecisive because
it causes us to you know stop for a
minute not be too hasty but in general
it's a
then he talks about courage and drinking
reluctance I'm gonna skip over those
then he talks about some other really
interesting things
remember back and we talked about
happiness in terms of Ducati Princess
Elizabeth dick Hart said that you could
be happy provided you didn't feel
certain emotions one of those was
remorse so what is remorse he says
remorse is a kind of sadness that comes
from a doubt doubt about whether
something we are giving or have done is
good this doubt is an essential feature
of it if we were quite sure that what
we're doing is bad we wouldn't do it we
do a lot of dumb things things that
actually turn out to be bad for us or
for other people because we don't think
them through well enough if we really
knew that they were bad we wouldn't
choose to do that because part of
recognizing something as bad as being
averse to hate but there's a lot of
things that we do it and later out of
the like yeah I'm not sure if that was
the right thing to do maybe I should
have told about this or maybe I maybe I
should have done this differently or
maybe I should have made this choice
that's remorse says if we're certainly
what we have done we've already done as
bad we would have repentance olders
sometimes we're just not sure and we
kind of like waver back and forth that's
the kind of sadness but it's also a kind
of anxiety and if you've ever felt that
you know it sucks it's really painful we
often feel this with with respect to
relationships or opportunities so that
that's remorse he also a little bit
later on talks about another related one
repentance he says repentance is a kind
of sadness which comes when we believe
we've actually done something bad we
recognize our failures we recognize that
we
something that we shouldn't have done
and what makes it so bitter is that we
realize it depends entirely on us we
could have chosen to do something
differently we didn't have to be a jerk
we didn't have to be soccer we'd have to
hasty yeah you can go wrong with this he
talks about a weak minded person
repenting is something they've done
without knowing for sure that was bad
they persuade themselves that it was bad
simply because they're afraid that it
was if they've done the opposite thing
they'd be afraid that that was the wrong
thing
should I ask this person out or not
asked about a very you know indecisive
person can feel repentance over either
their choice should I take this job or
not take this job again you can feel
repentance about that either choice but
if your firm you're only gonna feel
repentance if you've actually done
something that you recognize this via so
that's another set of modalities the
last one that I want to talk about you
have to do with our attitudes towards
other people doing things wrong and the
Curt makes a distinction I think it's
very good for us to make indignation and
anger to emotions that you're very
familiar with because you felt them a
lot but they're often hard to
distinguish from each other when you're
feeling them so what is indignation so
indignation is account hatred or
aversion that we naturally have towards
those who do some evil whatever it may
be so think for example about people who
recruit child soldiers largely in Africa
at this point on what's happened in
other places yeah I mean it's been going
on for several generations now where
they brutalize first they go into
villages let's get a lot of the older
people and they line up all the kids and
they say you you you you you you're not
in the army the army happens to be
usually it's a militia and then they
brutalize these kids just you know
subject them to horrific abuse and then
they tell them the abuse will stop if
you want to be a soldier and usually
being a soldier the way you get
initiated is you kill somebody else
start out by doing small stuff killing
some animals then start killing people
and these are kids who are you know nine
ten eleven years old
similar things that my boo's happened
with Pol Pot regime in Cambodia you can
read consider X recounting of
how these kids were returned into
it's very difficult to come up with a
better term than brutalised
turned into it so essentially something
like army ants pure instant pure heat
now when you hear about that sort of
thing if you have an emotional reaction
a pity for those kids that that's good
but if you also have an emotional
reaction of being feeling angry at those
people who are doing that that's not
actually anger that's actually
indignation you're not personally
involved I mean you clearly I suppose if
you knew somebody who's a child soldier
or something like that that's not the
case for most of us in the nation is
when you feel a sense of hatred or
aversion towards people who are doing
bad things
yang says often times it's mingled with
envy or pity but it has an object that's
totally different from those those two
passions we are indignant only towards
those who do good or evil to people who
don't deserve it we envy those who
receive this good and we pity those who
see this evil so this has to do with the
agent the person who's doing the things
we can be a big nipt about somebody
who's doing something bad to somebody
else
because they don't deserve it no child
deserves that sort of brutalization
I don't care what the kid has done
nobody else you could think about child
molesters too no child deserves to be
molested believe it or not there's
there's actually some philosophers just
goes to show you how people on the
fringe can think who you know came up
with like theories of the child seducing
the adult and all that that's that's
sort of crazy yeah as a matter of fact
when you hear about that you should
probably be indignant with those people
for suggesting is because they're kind
of doing extra harm to the kids aren't
they so it could be about doing wrong
that's not deserved it can also be about
giving some somebody else goods that
they don't deserve here's a great
example
in our current criminal justice regime
as a nation and I understand this
there's no one criminal justice system
and varies from state to state and state
is there one form of crime that we
probably have to strict sentences for
that pops up you can think of in terms
of the sort of damage that it does
lessons we said we spend a lot of people
to medium security prisons pretty small
drug charges not talking about you know
you know big distributors or the
enforcers or people like that I'm
talking about people selling small
amounts of drugs who didn't get caught
with it and get pretty stiff sentences
when you start comparing them to
kidnappings rape murder arson you know
much more violent crimes does that
bother you
if it does that could be a matter of
some sort of being indignant and you
could be indignant about the fact that
in some cases somebody might actually do
a horrible crime and get out of five
years because of the way the system
works well some other poor guy who you
know got caught selling drugs is 18
years old spends 20 years that would be
a matter of being indignant again you
don't have to be you don't have to be
personally involved to be indignant
that's actually where the dividing line
is between indignation and anger and he
says well oftentimes indignation is
accompanied by wonder you know we're
surprised that things are the way they
are and so sometimes it's even in a
accompanied by joy
now do we ever go wrong with indignation
you ever get indignant about things we
shouldn't sure he talks about that he
says it shows up much more in people who
are want to appear virtuous than those
who
really are some people become indignant
about trivial matters
some people get indignant about matters
for which no one can blame so those are
those are you know abuses what about
anger itself says anger is a hatred or
aversion we have towards those who have
done or tried to do harm
not just to someone but to us in
particular that does it have to be us
individually or it could be people
connected with us we can get angry on
behalf of people that are connected with
us so I might talk about your friend or
your your boyfriend or girlfriend or
your you know who's the parent you
probably never talk trash about right
dad dad could take care of himself
don't talk about people's moms alright
that sets people up why because they
they identify those people with
themselves remember what we talked about
is love when you love somebody you have
this sort of imagining themselves
imagining them to be part of a greater
whole that includes you and that person
is a part so if you have feelings of
love towards somebody and somebody
else's is making fun of them hurting
them you're going to get angry at that
person just as you would if they did
those sort of things to you it happens
even more so so he says anger is based
on an action that effects us and for
which we have a desire to avenge
ourselves that's the central desire in
anger revenge
he says anger is is the most violent of
the emotions because the desire to ward
off harmful things and to avenge oneself
is the most compelling of all desires
that's an interesting thing to think of
that do you think that's that's true do
you think that anger is the strongest of
the emotions or do you think that one
the other emotions this is a stronger
emotion for most people but love perhaps
or joy or sadness the car thinks of
anger is the one that's the strongest
and he says there's two kinds of anger
there is anger that sort of comes out
right away
he says flares up suddenly it's obvious
from the outside that has little effect
it can easily be calm and the kind of
people who get angry like this he says
are those who don't have deep hatred but
they have an instant aversion that takes
them by surprise they tend to imagine
everything want to happen the way they
think best so it doesn't happen they
wonder at it and they take offence they
they get upset you know some people like
that right they they're not angry people
per se but they're easy to anger but
once they get angry they don't stay that
injury the more dangerous kind of anger
he says is less obvious but it gnaws
more at the heart and has effects that
are more dangerous what happens with
this kinda anger who says hatred and
sadness predominates this is the kind of
anger that actually makes people angry
very often and passive-aggressive hidden
ways vengeful people he says the wrongs
that aroused somebody's anger appear
greater in proportion as vanity
increases their self-esteem also in
proportion of the evaluation of the good
things these wrongs take away so when
people have these things mixed up in
their head when they're wrong with other
passions they're liable to this more
noxious poisonous kind of anger that can
stay within a person and become a
lasting disposition affecting their
entire life their relationships and
their views on themselves I think that
you can see a lot of people exemplify
both kinds of anger you know in our
society perhaps you felt both of those
the last thing I'm going to touch on he
talks about Zayn Lorien shape and we're
rocking Rumble stuff vainglory is when
somebody thinks too highly of themselves
we've talked about this already and it
has to do with the hope of being praised
by others you know there's some people
who sort of only exist in other people's
estimation they are their Facebook
profile so to speak you know people like
that how many likes they get that date
you know their mood depends on that
shame is the opposite of that shame is a
kind of sadness also based on self-love
which also comes from expecting people
to blame you or criticize you and it's
different than modesty or the humility
these are these are emotions that we
would want to try to eliminate so what
the curt has given us here to some sum
up is sort of a road map for the
emotions if we understand the emotions
then we can begin to actually start to
take steps to control them to channel
them in the right directions to question
ourselves when we're feeling them and
then we can live a better life evenings